Olá você já parou para pensar que aquele
olhar atento do seu cão ou comportamento
estranho inusitado do seu gato pode
esconder algo significativo muito mais
profundo que você imagina desde os
tempos antigos animais e seres humanos
compartilham uma conexão inexplicável
que parece magia e se eu te contar que
muitos animais podem de fato pressentir
doenças em seus tutores quem cuida deles
muitas vezes antes mesmo dos primeiros
sintomas surgirem hoje eu vou
compartilhar histórias reais
emocionantes que revelam como nossos
amigos de quatro patas podem ser
verdadeiros anjos da guarda alertando-os
sobre problemas de saúde antes mesmo da
Medicina moderna detectar a tempo e eu
gostaria de saber você já viveu algo
assim conhece alguém que tenha passado
por uma experiência semelhante
compartilhe os comentários porque cada
relato conta e juntos podemos entender
melhor esse incrível fenômeno eu quero
começar contando a história de Mark
Allen um homem de 65 anos que mora em
Warwick Inglaterra para Mark tudo
começou de maneira silenciosa e quase
imperceptível o seu cão Jesse sempre foi
companheiro fiel Mas de repente começou
a agir de uma forma estranha o cachorro
não parava de cheirar insistentemente o
rosto de Mark algo que nunca tinha feito
antes aquele comportamento inusitado
chamou a atenção de Mark mas como muitos
de nós ele ignorou a princípio sem
imaginar que seu cão estava tentando
alertá-lo de algo muito sério então
meses se passaram e a insistência do cão
Jess ao redor do rosto de Mark só
aumentava então foi quando ele decidiu
buscar a ajuda médica então o
diagnóstico veio como um golpe
devastador o Mark estava com um tumor
agressivo que havia se espalhado pelo
lado direito do seu rosto algo que havia
ignorado por quase um ano o câncer já
estava em estágio avançado e Mark teve
que enfrentar uma cirurgia agressiva
complexa para remover o tumor uma
operação que reconstrui metade do seu
rosto essa história é um lembrete de que
devemos estar atentos aos sinais que a
vida nos dá muitas vezes através de quem
menos esperamos o cão gess de certa
forma salvou a vida de Mark e essa é
apenas uma das muitas histórias que nos
mostram o quanto Ainda temos aprender
com nossos companheiros de quatro patas
agora olha esse caso trisha Alisson de
wilford também da Inglaterra jamais
imaginou que a sua vida mudaria
drasticamente por causa de um simples
gesto de sua cadela Luna em um dia comum
enquanto trisha descansava no sofá
assistindo TV Luna uma mistura de galgo
com colle de apenas 2 anos fez algo
inesperado a cadela Luna pulou sobre o
peito de tr batendo em seu seio direito
até aí nada de incomum para muitos cães
Mas o que aconteceu depois chamou a
atenção de trisha Luna continuou a
cheirar e cutucar insistentemente o seu
peito e em vez de se afastar como de
costume ela se deitou ao lado de trisha
algo totalmente fora do normal para uma
cadela que segundo a própria trisha não
costumava deitar com os
tutores esse comportamento incomum
acendeu um alerta entre Então ela
decidiu que era hora de marcar uma
consulta médica então duas semanas
depois o diagnóstico que ninguém quer
ouvir ela estava com câncer de mama
tricha que trabalha como babá e já tinha
o hábito de se auto examinar a cada dois
meses nunca imaginou que a sua vida
seria salva por uma pata
intrometida as ações da canela Luna
levaram os seus médicos a descobrir o
Câncer em um estágio Inicial
possibilitando que que trisha passasse
por duas operações para remover os
tumores mesmo assim em meio ao caos
emocional há uma certeza que conforta
trisha o imenso agradecimento à sua
cadela Luna que com uma simpliza salvou
a sua vida não é de hoje que ouvimos
histórias de tutores que com espanto e
gratidão relatam a existência de seus
cães e gatos en cheiraram uma parte
específica do corpo apenas para
descobrir mais tarde que ali estava se
desenvolvendo um câncer pode parecer
coincidência mas a verdade é que esses
comportamentos TM uma base científica
fascinante a ciência já está de olho
nesse poderoso talento natural que é o
olfato canino como uma ferramenta de
detecção precoce de câncer Então temos
várias pesquisas em andamento pesquisas
em universidades norte-americanas tê
revelado que cães podem de fato detectar
vários tipos de Câncer com seu ofato
muito apurado seu ofato Extra ordinário
então entre os tipos de câncer que já
mostraram ser identificáveis por esses
narizes apurados estão câncer de pulmão
intestino ovário próstata mama e até
melanoma assim como outras doenças o
câncer libera marcadores químicos que em
alguns casos podem ser detectados nos
fluídos humanos então cães treinados
para essa missão tão especial podem
conseguir identificar a presença desses
compostos na pele na urina no hálito nas
feses suor dos pacientes e o mais
impressionante os resultados têm se
mostrado extremamente eficientes Vale
lembrar que os cães são capazes de
detectar substâncias e concentrações
mínimas estamos falando de partes por
bilão Então esse fato nos leva a pensar
talvez em um futuro próximo nossos
melhores amigos possam estar ao lado dos
médicos na luta contra o câncer não
apenas oferecendo conforto e companhia
mas também desempenhando um papel
fundamental um papel Vital na detecção
precoce da doença é uma parceria entre
ciência e natureza que pode salvar
incontáveis vidas Além disso o talento
desses cães vai além da detecção de
câncer existem cães especialmente
treinados para detectar mudanças dos
níveis de açúcar no sangue de seus
tutores veja bem o seu cão pode virar um
detector de glicose alertando Então os
tutores sobre episódios de hipoglicemia
antes mesmo sintomas se tornarem graves
esses cães heróis são capazes de
reconhecer mudanças sutis no cheiro do
alito de seus donos que indicam
variações nos níveis de glicose em casos
mais avançados esses cães não só alertam
o tutor mas também são treinados para
pegar a medicação e entregar os seus
donos proporcionando um auxílio Vital em
momentos críticos além da capacidade de
detectar câncer e prevenir crises de
hipoglicemia os cães têm mostrado uma
impressionante variedade de habilidades
na detecção de doenças e condições
médicas que podem salvar vidas por
exemplo cães treinados podem identificar
sinais de ataques epilépticos iminentes
em seus tutores muitas vezes
alertando-os minutos antes da ocorrência
e assim permitindo que eles possam se
preparar ou buscar ajuda isso é
particularmente importante para pessoas
que T epilepsia porque uma convulsão
Inesperada pode pode resultar em
ferimentos graves então outra atuação
notável desses cães é na detecção de
crises
cardíacas cães de alerta médico Podem
perceber mudanças sutis no comportamento
de seus donos que indicam que algo está
errado como um ataque cardíaco iminente
então eles são treinados para buscar
ajuda ou acionar alarmes nesses casos
que pode ser uma diferença crítica em
emergências onde cada segundo conta
esses cães também desempenho um papel
fundamental na assistência a Pessoas com
Transtorno de estresse pós-traumático
eles são treinados para interromper
episódios de ansiedade intensa acalmando
seus tutores e até buscando medicamento
Se necessário mas e os gatos bem os
felinos também TM as suas próprias
histórias incríveis para contar
histórias que destacam um vínculo
profundo e misterioso que compartilham
com seus tutores vamos conhecer rock um
gato preto cuja ligação com a sua dona
foi Além da simples companhia rock era
um gato especial especialmente sensível
ao estado de saúde da sua tutora que
sofria de Artrite psoriática Então
sempre que a dor tomava conta dela rock
se deitava exatamente sobre o local
dolorido o calor de sua barriga e o som
reconfortante de seu ronronar
proporcionava um alívio que se
assemelhava a uma massagem mas rock fez
ainda algo mais notável ele começou a
colocar sapato exatamente no local onde
uma uma massa estava se formando na
parede abdominal da sua dona algo que os
médicos não tinham detectado essa massa
que mais tarde Foi confirmado como
decorrente de endometriose e suas
aderências passou despercebida pelos
exames médicos no entanto rock com sua
sensibilidade não só ajudava a aliviar a
dor como parecia absorver parte do
sofrimento da sua tutora chegando Até
vomitar após confortá-la sua decepção e
apoio foram essenciais pro bem-estar
dela durante anos então também temos a
história de og um gato que literalmente
salvou a vida de sua dona og sempre
gostou de se aconchegar perto dela mas
algo mudou quando ele começou a insistir
em deitar sobre o lado esquerdo do seu
peito esse comportamento inusitado levou
a dona a realizar um auto exame e
descobriu eventualmente o nódulo então
após avaliar esse nódulo com exames veio
o diagnóstico câncer de mama estágio
três a dona acredita que o comportamento
de og foi uma tentativa desesperada de
alertá-la sobre o problema antes mesmo
que os médicos pudessem fazê-lo essas
histórias podem parecer incríveis
fantásticas mas não são isoladas há
vários relatos de gatos que detectaram
Câncer em seus tutores em um caso um
gato alertou sua dona sobre um câncer de
mama ao pular repetidamente sobre o seio
afetado em outro um gato arrastava sua
pata sem parar pelo lado esquerdo do
corpo do seu dono onde mais tarde foi
descoberto um grande tumor
pulmonar embora esses casos sejam
principalmente histórias informais eles
sugerem que os gatos podem ter um papel
inexplorado para detectar doenças
através do seu olfato e sensibilidade se
você se interessou por esses assuntos
por essas histórias e quer entender mais
sobre o cheiro como ele pode revelar
muito sobre a nossa saúde não deixe de
assistir Meu outro vídeo sobre esse
assunto sobre o cheiro das doenças nele
eu também exploro a incrível habilidade
dos animais de detectar esses odores o
link está na descrição além de suas
habilidades para detectar doenças Cães e
Gatos oferecem um apoio emocional
inestimável para seus tutores
especialmente em momentos de doenças
graves a presença constante e o carinho
incondicional desses animais ajudam a
reduzir os níveis de estresse e de
ansiedade proporcionando conforto e
segurança estudos mostram que interagir
com o animal de estimação Pode liberar o
hormônio chamado oxitocina que promove
sentimentos de bem-estar e também de
afeto de carinho reduz a percepção da
dor em meio a tratamentos difíceis como
quimioterapia ou recuperação de
cirurgias o simples ato de qualquer cão
de ser acariciado ou de acariciar pode
trazer grande alívio emocional ajudando
o paciente a enfrentar os desafios com
mais força e
resiliência essas histórias nos lembram
de que nossos animais de Mação sejam
cães gatos ou outros estão muito mais
conectados conosco do que podemos
imaginar quem sabe com mais estudos nós
possamos então poder entender melhor
essas incríveis habilidades e usá-las
para salvar aa mais vidas muito obrigado
pela sua atenção um grande abraço um
beijo no seu coração Você é fera